the ad world is in for rude awakening
the same way the car industry was
when it had an innovation called Tesla I
think it's the same way Hollywood
Network companies were when they had
Netflix you know I often think that
vaynermedia is the preview to all the
agencies of 20 years from now not
because I'm so smart or we're so smart
or we're so special there's a secret
word that the ad industry has to adopt
fast and it's a word that the industry
does not know how to handle and that
word is humility
we of course we want to hear all about
the future you are about the future we
talk about a lot about found content and
and making more content and making more
things out of other things and how how
fun it is and how easy it is but I want
to hear what you are looking at uh just
a general sense of what you're looking
at in 2023 what is uh sparking your
brain and what will you be uh thinking
about in the months ahead
um
AI copywriting is probably at the top of
my list of futuristic stuff you know it
was funny when you said you're all about
the future my brain went the present I
think the world thinks a lot of things
that I'm excited about like I don't
guess I don't want to do something that
nobody's doing yet
so you know I've been looking at AI
stuff machine learning stuff for years
as an investor as a as hey when will
this happen and then you know uh earlier
this fall
you know Chad gbt you look at that
you're like wait a minute this is real
like I can write an entire blog post in
two minutes and what I'm excited about
is you know I've seen some counterpoints
in Social where people are like this is
bad this is going to take away jobs and
like yeah and I'm like yeah but you know
if you know your history that's what
people said about tractors
yeah you know tractors were bad we
shouldn't make right we shouldn't make
farming you know uh you know uh
things like I'm trying to remember what
Machinery we should make farming
Machinery that will take away jobs what
happens is when jobs are taken away new
jobs are created
yeah and what I see in in copywriting AI
is
the commodity is being
disrupted
but you know you have to come up with
the ideas like I have to say hey write a
blog post about the friends and compare
it to wine and say it in the voice of
Chris Farley
and then enter and then I've got to edit
it so ideas and creativity go to the top
the commodity of the execution goes to
the bottom and Tom obviously we've had
the luxury of jamming together you know
that I I in a lot of ways and very
traditional to advertising I think the
creative is the variable of success I
think ideas are incredibly the beginning
point of that
um but obviously you know given your
career like I have a very different
point of view of the process of that
less politics of one human being
subjective opinion based on seniority
more making at scale and looking at
consumer insights to make better uh that
is not test and learn that's marketing
with the sake of making better marketing
so you know I think AI copywriting is at
the tippy top
um and then the continuation more of the
same in 2023 I think we'll see more
people understand that you have to make
different commercials
for for CTV like a Hulu commercial an
Amazon Prime commercial a you know a
future Netflix commercial if you make
what we all know as commercials for that
space it's going to be bad and so like
let's make think videos that people
actually want to watch
um more more uh Tick Tock the organic
reach is subsiding because more people
are making for it more ads are being run
so now you have to be better to break
through right yeah uh other platforms do
I mean Instagram put out a feature this
week where you know all of a sudden the
DM ecosystem looks differently there's
some WhatsApp Behavior I just put in you
know a post in there what are they
officially calling it
notes this notes feature like I just put
in like what's your favorite wine boom
getting a ton of Engagement like oh
attention UI ux so the platforms you
know Facebook reels crushing for me
right uh creative strategy doing green
screens over headlines as your creative
versus just ranting to the video so the
creative strategy of these platforms
that are mature like YouTube you know
thought you know we hear all the you
know when I hear Mr Beast talk about
spending six figures on a thumbnail
just imagine you know uh uh we we've uh
there's a daily B which is my daily blog
that got a million views after three
title changes and four thumbnail changes
versus 40 000 views like you know
there's like really incredible you know
creative strategy that is going to
continue to build I think in 2023 more
people are going to buy into it I'm
seeing the term clip agencies pop up
which is like agencies yeah there's a
term I saw in my Tick Tock three
different tick tocks I've seen the last
three weeks of like clip agencies or new
or the new website agencies the guy was
comparing it that he had a website
agency in the 90s because everybody
needed one now clip agencies which is
the essence of what I've been doing for
10 years which is like micro creative
like what I do every day we put out 15
Clips today on YouTube and they're
calling them clip agencies I thought it
was clever I'm like oh it's just so
funny to see like that you know is
becoming the science that people are
trying to understand while still as I'm
looking outside in New York City I'm
looking at two outdoor uh Billboards
one's for apple and I'm looking at the
creative and I'm like look that's a very
busy street 10th Avenue in New York City
like when you buy Billboards properly
not overpay but maybe by Remnant
inventory you get the billboard for two
months at like 80 percent of the cost
you know
that's a deal of awareness that's New
York City a lot of people will see it
actually even with people looking at
their phones I still think the drivers I
know you lost the passenger because of
the phone but even the driver though
with Tesla people in but nonetheless for
now as long as we're trying I look at
that I'm like oh that might be a deal
but then I'm like but is that the right
creative and I know and you know Tom
99.9 likely that somebody just came up
with that and they and somebody else
said that's good and they went
to me not testing images on Twitter and
Instagram and other Pinterest to get to
here are my 37 hypotheses
yeah and and I just use the word I don't
want to use I don't want to use test
Market pictures on those platforms have
actual humans respond to it and then
have affirmation of this image is most
likely to make someone stop or pay
attention I'm gonna it's just crazy we
we continue to do marketing as if the
internet doesn't exist right how how do
you
to follow up on that how are how are our
clients going to have to change well you
know this uh in the future you know yeah
it's a new generation of marketer you
know this again this is the beauty of
like this is so fun this you know I
wanted to do this for you too because I
want to support you because once Vayner
always Vayner and so you know that you
know this brother you came from the
industry you spent time at Vayner you
know it's hard it's hard for us we we
are trying to teach people a new game
it's like hey I know you've been playing
you know
hockey for the last 40 years we'd like
you to play Pickleball and they're like
what
but it's a sport but it's not the same
and so you know this like even you I
don't know if this Serendipity of the
accounts you worked on Tom and I think
with Pepsi I'm trying to think might
have not hated Budweiser might have not
hit your radar as much but no no it
wasn't this it's just a Serendipity of
the accounts you were on we have
accounts that I can think of that you
weren't on that literally the results
like literally the business is up for
the first time in a long time
yeah but because but because it's not
what they want which is like let's just
all sit around for seven months come up
with an idea and throw it on TV they're
like they're like not fully happy
they're like no but we should do like
they're always fighting for it to go
back to the old way
yeah and so the modern marketer is gonna
have to be like the modern parent right
like the modern parents got to realize
that eighth place trophies for the last
20 years have really [ __ ] kids up
I know the intent was good we didn't
want kids to be upset that's beautiful I
don't think parents 25 years ago when
this started being a trend were trying
to upset kids in their 20s and 30s with
anxiety and fear of losing they were
trying to address the issue at hand
which was you know if this kid gets a
trophy and my son's coming home or
daughter and they're crying that's bad
so the logic there was there
yeah but it ended up here we are now
2023 and we do have an incredible issue
in society which is that we've demonized
losing so much that kids fear so much
now they don't want to do they're like
scared to do anything to the point where
like it's even like hot to be like I
don't want to work
right that's not sustainable that's just
not how the you know and so you know I
think the same thing with marketers I
don't think the marketers or the
creatives I bring in or strategies I
bring in are ill intent
I think they just don't see the
consequences of not adjusting to the
truth
and what's adjusting look like what what
are what are the realizing that brand is
built in Social let's start there right
now you've been taught I love that
phrase I mean it's built in Social I
mean it means that the brands that are
winning are quite effective in social
media marketing or on their product and
they don't have to be effective in TV
commercials and above the line branding
and the brands that are losing market
share are betting the farm on above the
line branding and TB executions and it's
just black and white and the only
enigmas are the ones that have the
product is so much better I've always
said that I felt that Apple for the last
decade has not been as effective of
marketers people think but it's been
hidden because they're the best product
hmm and you see it because you see way
too many people consider Android and
youth culture when that shouldn't be the
case when Apple's a much better product
yeah it's that they're not winning on
relevance as much as people think they
might be and so you know I think there's
this big bad game of relevance and
consideration that is very classic
marketing jogger that that television
and above the line vanilla sentences for
brand positioning are unable to achieve
because they box everyone into matching
luggage and digital most of its
traditional digital it goes programmatic
banner and Impressions instead of social
first creative against consumer
segmentations to win on relevance and
then extract consumer insights and go up
on what you want to bet on so it's going
to take everyone to flip the whole model
which is incredibly challenging you have
an entire industry of marketers and
creatives and strategists who were built
on
fake research or limited it's not fake
that's not fair but very limited
research you go to Reddit you go to the
internet you do a little research you
survey 20 to 50 people and you come in
and you pitch an idea that came out of
brilliant creative minds but like the
reality is is like it's just not working
and so
I think a lot more creative the cost of
creative has to come down
we can't think good creative is just
based on how much it cost
right like I want to remind people you
guys yeah exactly yeah I want to remind
people many people every person here
who's listening you have had a 600
dinner not every person because not
everyone's fortunate enough to have this
kind of dinner for the people that have
but you know I've stumbled on it one way
or another we're only for the upper
echelon this podcast no but but Top
Notch but but really like you know
people go with a boss and they get to
like like there have been people who've
had their first actually here's a better
way for the people that have been lucky
enough to have a fancy meal a white
tablecloth meal yeah many of us
listening right now can know that
they've had meals that cost 500 bucks
with the wine and the high-end food and
the caviar this and the sweet breads
that and the Foie grab this or whatever
it may be high-end Sushi and then we've
also had like a Bojangles chicken
sandwich for a dollar or whatever the
hell it is five bucks and like the five
dollar one was more satisfying and more
effective than the 600 one wine bourbon
sodas and take any consumable uh clothes
there's people that have a 47 pair of
jeans that they love 10 times more than
a 300 and so somehow we realize
subconsciously if not consciously that
in the world there's a lot of things we
like more that don't cost as much we
like it more
yeah yet in the creative ad world
quality is completely completely tied
into subconsciously to how much it cost
a tick tock that gets 80 trillion views
can't be as good as a commercial that
runs on NBC prime time because that one
cost eight hundred dollars or three
thousand dollars and the other one cost
a million yeah with production and
agency fee and talent a director and
right when in reality every day on Tick
Tock there's 45 pieces of marketing
creative that will be seen by 10
trillion times more people than any
commercial on network television and be
more effective for the business that is
not accepted in our industry yet
but it is an inevitable outcome of
tomorrow
a lot more stuff yeah yeah go ahead and
when you talk about driving the cost of
creative down I sort of feel like that
brings us back to
station right because that's where we
can drive the cost of this stuff down if
it all comes down to the prompt the idea
the thing that you're putting into the
engine as being the premium thing that
is uniquely human
then the the degeneration of that
content can become commoditized
um it can drive the cost of that
creative down and shouldn't the way I
look at automation is not so much a
threat to jobs I think about it as a a
response to volume our ability to then
do more it's it's it's it's even the
people yeah it but it but it is
replacing certain people like the
architect is different than the Mason
um I think what it does is so that's an
interesting question Gary I'm curious
understand when we think about so you
when we think about the future and and
the tools of the present that are moving
us into the future what are those job
shifts what are the new jobs going to be
in the next couple of years as a result
of all this I've got jobs at your agency
that I had never seen before which is
post-creative strategist which I was so
obsessed with because I'm like what is
that that is the key because that's the
difference for me that's the thing I see
that's different yeah and I wanted to
dig into that so hard you know the PCS
somebody who reads qualitative feedback
and can make an observation from it to
then dictate better creative the next
time
that's right so if we play out Ai and
say hey everyone bad news
seven years from now instead of actually
writing out the copy just an idea person
could do what I just did earlier and
it's all written out so that's clearly a
job
right uh bad news everybody if you make
you know pictures uh to post on the
internet in Adobe
like in 17 years that's been replaced by
somebody just saying make a cow with
Sunshine On It Go and there it is right
yeah what I say though is good news
everybody all the people that have these
brilliant ideas that are doing other
things do you know many people actually
have the best ideas who are cashiers at
Starbucks that if they knew that this
technology existed
they would be creative directors
how about that you know we don't think
about the things that technology do you
know when people are making a hundred
thousand dollars a year in YouTube ads
that otherwise would have been making
forty thousand dollars a year doing
something they don't want to do so
everyone goes right away into like
demonizing technology oh here this comes
it's going to eliminate Junior
copywriters
okay but Junior copywriters eliminated
something too like when advertising came
out what happened to the salesman
if we had no advertising wouldn't
everybody be a Salesman the answer is
yes just real quick if there was no
branding in advertising would people be
knocking on people's door and saying
would you like to buy this cup of coffee
let me save everyone time the answer is
yes
and so there's always things that happen
I'm happy that Cree I think it's a game
of creativity getting even more oomph
right it becomes more about the idea
than the slog of the execution we all
know that ever please there's a great
there's a word for that which is
democratization right it's becoming
democratized I love this idea that ideas
come from the Barista at Starbucks
that's right but that's what that's what
the iPhone has done right 100 of this
camera inside of that phone is going to
surpass the slrs by next year it's crazy
and Tom you know this which means we
have five billion people with
professional devices in their pockets
yep that has implications it's already
played out look who the most famous
people are to a 17 year old around the
world let's go talk to every 15 year old
in the world and say write down the five
most famous people I promise you that a
lot of them do not live on television
that was on that's in I'm 47 years old
that was inconceivable when I was 17.
how ready Gary are my our marketers
today for this moment
how many are ready for this moment a
number that you don't work is there I'm
I'm already misunderstood in our
industry I'm petrified to answer you
the number is staggering and it's not
their faults I don't think the ad
industry and the CMOS and the marketers
of Fortune 500 are less smart less nice
less good the game is broken
the reporting the incentives the
realities
I I can think of 400 people I've met on
Instagram DM that are creators that are
more prepared than anybody I can think
of in adland
yeah you can't be prepared if your job
is to work on a project for nine months
to come up with a slogan and make one
commercial you can't be prepared
yeah
and they're still even even with the uh
the Creator economy that we talked I was
just reading this article that Annalisa
had sent to me about the Creator economy
and how it was a misnomer because it's
like the Creator economy actually only
pertains to the top one percent because
what do we do we always go back to our
course it's like well who are the best
influencers not give me influence well
it depends but but I I didn't I didn't
read that article but I will say this
um I will say that that in itself may be
a misnomer as well let me explain
to the point I think Society has
completely confused on what success
looks like to that article's point if
I'm catching this right yes there are
far less people making four million
dollars a year being Logan Paul and Mr
Beast and Charlie demilio however
I know personally as a human being
thousands of people that make 50 to 200
000 a year being a creator
and that is again back to the analogy
earlier I'll give you the perfect
example I know somebody right now who's
a fitness Creator is a friend of a
friend they got inspired by the books I
got the email I read it and then it was
like kind of hit me I call the person
I think she's gonna make 133 000 this
year she was making 280 as a lawyer her
life is 4 000 times better we haven't
even started that combo you know we've
always had it as oh you make more now
than the thing what about if you make
less but you're a happy person yeah well
that's but that goes back to the success
metrics too that goes back to the the
value structure that we have yes it
costs more and reports more valuable
correct I mean make more there for my
life is better that it's crazy it's
crazy oh my God such a good point so I
think look I think the ad world is in
for rude awakening the same way the car
industry was
when it had an innovation called Tesla I
think it's the same way Hollywood
Network companies were when they had
Netflix you know I often think that
vaynermedia is the preview to all the
agencies of 20 years from now not
because I'm so smart or we're so smart
or we're so special there's a secret
word that the ad industry has to adopt
fast and it's a word that the industry
does not know how to handle and that
word is humility
I would argue that the word that the
most senior creatives and most senior
strategist at the Ad Agency in the world
really have to factor into their
day-to-day is humility because what
comes along with democratization is
humility right Tom you know again you
you've been under the hood right right
like you know all of a sudden you think
everybody thinks they're a hot shop
because they're uh you know an ecd at
droga what an iconic Place David drug is
one of the nicest people I've met in
this industry I'm so pumped for their
success and by the way many people I
meet at why didn't drug have lost a
wonderful Super Creative I love it I go
to can mainly because I'm so head down
and I don't know much about the industry
I mainly go to can to stumble into
people of the industry because it's
lovely but yeah but
with all that said
the thought that a kid at a school even
a good AD school like Miami AD school
right most these CDs at big shops will
not think that at first day Miami AD
school person has a better idea than
them and I know it to be true
ideas are Talent
Kobe Bryant was good at 19. he didn't
have to be 35. and marketing is like
Sports Marketing is like Sports
Marketing is like sports
hmm
right John Mcenroe was good at 17 in
tennis
he was worse actually at 35 and I think
that's marketing I think a lot of people
get worse in this industry because
they've become too consumed
client-centric instead of
consumer-centric
that's right I
I then the more relevant your idea I
mean you have to be able to communicate
oh I see it all the time and by the way
let me flip it on the other side I'm
watching 42 year olds coming into the
business who understand the consumer
better than a lot of the 22 year olds
that work for me are going into rude
awakening they're like I know everything
about social I'm 22. I'm like hooking up
through DMs is different than marketing
to sell [ __ ] yeah yeah and so they come
like I've been enjoying it I had a great
meeting the other day where I kind of
like
played them into it like yeah yeah yeah
and I was like what about everything
that's actually been going on for the
last four months they're like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I'm like yeah like cool like
you're like cool that you care about it
but are you good at it
like I'm 40 I'm 47. that's humility yeah
like where where do you need to get
better and how are you doing that what's
your plan yeah I'll tell you why my team
knows this I don't react to virality
when we crush it when a garyvee video I
got three million on this green screen
the other day no reaction I get 40 000
views on something that completely like
like one of the worst pieces of content
I put out from performance and I'm like
in there like isn't this [ __ ] great
what does it mean let's talk about it
more let's [ __ ] on me more this was mine
I'm the worst like like that's just
lacking like and for everybody who's
listening don't confuse conviction
as an opposite to humility it's actually
beautiful Partners to dance you can have
conviction
but when proven otherwise you better
deploy humility I have conviction in
everything I do but when the market the
consumer says no Gary then I deploy
humility and I watch everybody in this
industry use headlines at ad age or ad
week Awards and and seniority and where
they work and some other cockamanian
[ __ ] as the justification why
they're right in the face of them being
wrong
yeah it's it's all about ease for a lot
of people it's all about just like how
do I make my job easy well this is
awesome well and not only that that's a
good call out and I I have empathy for
that because the world's stressful and
people you know like shit's stressful I
think this goes all the way to the tippy
top of the global CEOs of the five six
holding companies they have to realize
that they're running their companies
with fear
yeah and and fear is the quickest way to
suck out creativity if if Tom is if I am
if like if we're in meetings and we hear
that we lost the McDonald's account and
our brain is actually thinking like will
I be let go
versus what idea should I come up with
for chicken nuggets that's so I think my
observation is that the holding the
creative agencies are now owned by Banks
Banks run with very little emotional
intelligence it's really not about the
people it's about the p l
and that has created a culture of fear
in adland I now know this to be true
because it takes us a long time to get
people to feel safer and a lot of times
you know it's a big new revelation for
me even this year like next year like
we're going to give people a lot more
time before they even work on anything
if they've been in the ad world for a
long time because it it's harder for us
to get them to feel safe than we
realized
if I if I gave you a million dollars
would you rather make one spot or a
hundred a thousand
exactly and so I think the the when we
when the price tag is so high the fear
goes up right because then oh my gosh I
better get the return of that investment
what an investment well it's even worse
that I know we're going over time I
apologize at the end of the year I gotta
get a lot done but I'll leave it with
this it's even worse than that right
because all the reporting like the
justification how do you measure brand
that's like asking somebody to measure
God and love but there's reports for it
there's a [ __ ] Miller Brown report
for it there's a [ __ ] Nielsen's
report for it there's a [ __ ] client
internal mmm for it but it's fake my
friends it's Santa Claus measuring brand
is Santa Claus
right so the even the incentives and you
know this and at least like like we have
clients that say Gary we want to do
award-winning work I'm like why
well it's better for sales I'm like not
really here's how the report came about
it was incentivized for Creative
agencies to sell you that [ __ ] and
more importantly you're really doing it
because you want self-interest for your
career so when you're named that at
canned you can get another CMO job so
let's talk real talk friends yeah
like why do people want to be associated
with things that the industry talks
about because it gets them jobs because
agency owners like myself I don't do
this but like I know this is what the
industry does you look at a thing it's
like oh this thing's hot oh who are the
creative directors oh go to LinkedIn oh
hey Sally you want a job I'll promote
you from an ACD to a CD from a CD to a
gcd from a gcd 2d like can we call out
the game can we call out the game
because it's definitely not working and
what I'm most worried about is back to
all the lovely people this is my last
point I promise I'm sorry team
I don't think people know how big the
Day of Reckoning is there's a reason so
many people are getting left go in
Hollywood that work in networks it's
because they lost I don't think people
realize that if they don't adjust soon
the top 45 creative agencies over a
decade will lose 50 market share meaning
80 percent of the staff will be let go
and when they get let go for being in
the old game the new winners aren't
going to be rushing to hire someone
who like thinks that they should get a
brief yeah 100 at the point the point
isn't so much it's not so much if it's
really when and and and are we are are
our clients ready correct how can we
help them get more ready to be calling
out the rules or what's broken yeah and
look CMOS there's a reason CMOS are 18
months and that's going to trickle down
to our agencies and it already has yeah
like like honestly I have no Pride or
excitement about our hyper growth
because I know it because I know it's
coming at the expense of people that
like when we win I'm happy for my team
it's what I'm supposed to do but my
brain always goes like when we lose
business
I I just run on Lower margin and try to
figure it out
when they lose business they fire
everyone that was on that account
and so my brain goes we just want a big
big piece of business literally after
yay my brain went into like [ __ ] like
those like I know what's gonna happen on
the other side across the street you
know and so our industry needs to get
healthier Kinder more empathetic we got
to figure [ __ ] out I call for the agency
owners to have create more margins so
that when they lose business they don't
have to fire everyone which will
immediately make people feel safer
which will immediately make people more
creative all right gotta go love you
thanks Gary cheers
[Music]